impregnable that's how the Vale sees
itself shielded from Westeros by its
mountains they call the entrance to
their lands the bloody gate because
during the Age of Heroes a dozen armies
supposedly smashed themselves against it
even if they'd gotten through the roads
of the Vale a narrow steep from
treacherous half the men would have
slipped to their deaths or frozen in the
mountain snow or so the common wisdom
goes except the Vale has been conquered
those vaunted mountains didn't stop the
Andals who came by the eastern sea the
people of the vales say that sir artists
Arryn the Andal general flew on the back
of a giant falcon and slew the Gryphon
King on top of the tallest mountain
during Aegon's conquest one of his
sisters did the same flying her dragon
over the bloody gate and up to the Eyrie
the Arryn stronghold and the errand boy
King yielded the Vale in return for a
ride on the Beast do you sense the theme
here the rationalizing of defeats with
mythical beasts and the whims of
children instead of acknowledging the
root cause the arrogance of isolation
the men of the Vale are so proud of
their mountains they can't abide any
flaw in them as with the mountains so
true with their blood
the first Andals landed in the vale as
its most powerful Lords the errands the
weighing words the core Bray's like to
brag through their veins runs the blood
of the oldest Handel nobility in
Westeros but through their brains runs
an even older folly that blood matters
if it did those pure born Lords should
have been able to exterminate the hill
tribes centuries ago but those primitive
Raiders who strives more resemble
candles than families continued to
plague the Vale even kidnapping an
errand once until Tyrion Lannister an
outsider nove Lord ever thought to turn
the tribes to the vales advantage
that a desperate warlike people could be
useful not to mention inexpensive but
perhaps the Veii lords consider such
thoughts beneath them after all the
veils isolation does breed an abundance
of honor and pious bleating which
governs their decisions instead of
foresight like a blind man who can only
guess where his horse is taking him
I doubt Jon Arryn had even prepared for
Civil War when he raised his banners
instead of handing over his young Ward's
Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon to the
Mad King honor demanded and Lord Arryn
obeyed he'd have done the same if the
boys hadn't been the Lords of two Great
Houses who could field mighty armies of
their own but perhaps I give him too
little credit after all if the war went
against them only Lord Arryn had a nice
impregnable castle to retreat him to and
he was wise enough to take poor Lysa
Tully into his bed
to win the Riverlands as allies Jon
Arryn won then Jon Arryn died wisely the
Vale stayed out of all the ensuing chaos
its crops did not burn a wither in the
fields from lack of men to tend them its
strength was not drained by forced
marches to futile skirmishes in the Vale
life proceeds as it always has
Tom proud a world of high honor
understood by armies and men of low
birth but high ambition impregnable